양자 정보와 계산 이해하기 강의에 다시 오신 걸 환영해요. 저는 John Wattress이고 IBM
Quantum의 교육 기술 총괄 디렉터예요. 이번이 시리즈의 16번째이자 마지막 강의이고, 오늘 주제는 내결함성 양자
컴퓨팅이에요. 지난 세 강의에서 양자 오류 정정 코드의 여러 예시를 살펴봤는데요, 이 코드들은 오류가 너무 많이 발생하지 않는 한 양자 오류를 감지하고
정정할 수 있어요. 그런데 양자 컴퓨팅에 오류 정정을 실제로 적용하려면 아직 해결해야 할 문제들이 많이 있어요. 예를 들어, 우리가 쓰는 양자 gate, 측정, 그리고 상태
준비 자체가 불완전할 수 있다는 현실이 있죠. 예를 들어, 양자 오류 정정 코드로 인코딩된
하나 이상의 qubit에 오류 정정을 수행하려면, 그 자체로 오류가 생길 수 있는 gate와 측정을 사용해야 해요.
그 gate와 측정이 제대로 작동하지 않을 가능성이 있다는 뜻이에요. 그건 오류를 감지하거나 정정하지 못할 뿐만 아니라
새로운 오류를 도입할 수도 있다는 의미예요. 게다가 우리가 실제로 수행하고 싶은 계산도 완전하지 않은 gate로
실행해야 해요. 그리고 계산을 위해 양자 정보를 디코딩했다가
다시 인코딩하는 방식은 절대 쓸 수 없어요. 양자 오류 정정 코드의 보호가 없는 순간에 오류가 발생할 수 있거든요.
이 말은 양자 오류 정정 코드의 보호를 한 번도 벗어나지 않으면서 논리적 qubit에 직접 양자 gate를 수행하는 방법을 찾아야 한다는 뜻이에요.
굉장히 어려운 요구지만, 노이즈 수준이
특정 임계값 아래로 떨어지는 한, 노이즈가 있는 하드웨어로도 임의로 큰 양자 계산을 안정적으로 수행하는 것이 실제로 가능해요.
적어도 이론적으로는요. 이 아주 중요한 사실에 대해서는 강의 후반부에 다룰 거예요.
이번 강의의 간략한 개요를 살펴볼게요. 먼저 내결함성 양자 컴퓨팅의 기본 모델과 노이즈 모델에 대한 간략한 설명부터 시작해서,
양자 circuit을 내결함성 방식으로 구현하는 일반적인 방법론을 다룰 거예요.
그다음엔 내결함성 양자 circuit에서의 오류 전파 문제와 그것을
어떻게 제어할지 살펴볼 거예요. 특히, 오류 전파를 제어하는 아주 간단한 방법인 횡단적 gate 구현에 대해 이야기할 건데,
이 방법만으로는 해결할 수 없는 근본적인 한계도 있어요.
또한 소위 magic state를 이용하는 다른 방법론도 이야기할 텐데, 이건 오류 전파를 제어하는 또 다른 경로를 제공해요.
물론 이게 유일한 방법은 아니에요. 마지막으로 강의는
방금 잠깐 언급했던 임계값 정리에 대한 꽤 높은 수준의 논의로 마무리돼요.
이 정리는 모든 구성 요소의 오류율이 특정 유한한 임계값 아래로 떨어지는 한
임의로 큰 양자 circuit을 안정적으로 구현할 수 있다는 내용이에요. 일반적으로 이 임계값은
우리가 사용하는 오류 정정 코드와 내결함성 구현을 위한 구체적인 선택에 따라 달라지지만,
구현되는 circuit의 크기에는 영향을 받지 않아요. 이건 대규모
양자 계산이 언젠가는 현실이 될 거라고 믿을 충분한 이유가 돼요. 내결함성 양자
컴퓨팅의 기본 모델 이야기부터 시작할게요. 자연스럽게 양자 circuit과 양자 오류 정정 코드에 기반해요. 이 논의를 위해,
구현하고 싶은 양자 circuit이 하나 있다고 상상해 봐요. 여기 보이는 것처럼요.
이건 EBIT 준비를 포함한 텔레포테이션 circuit인데, 이 논의에서 세부 사항은 크게 중요하지 않아요.
어떤 다른 양자 circuit이라도 괜찮아요. 상태 준비, 유니터리
연산, 측정을 포함한 훨씬 더 큰 circuit을 상상해도 돼요.
이 circuit은 물론 이상적인 경우를 나타내고, 실제
구현은 완벽하지 않을 거예요. 자연스럽게 드는 질문은 뭐가
잘못될 수 있냐는 거예요. 사실 잘못될 수 있는 게 꽤 많아요. 예를 들어, 상태 초기화가 일반적으로
완벽하지 않을 거예요. 물론 유니터리 gate도 완벽하지 않고
측정도 마찬가지예요. 게다가 qubit 자체도 계산의 모든 순간에 노이즈, 특히 결어긋남에 취약해요.
qubit에 아무것도 하지 않고 그냥 양자 정보를 저장하고 있을 때도 마찬가지예요. 한마디로
거의 모든 게 잘못될 수 있어요. 하지만 한 가지 예외가 있어요. 아니면 적어도 일반적인 가정이 있는데,
관련된 고전적 계산은 아마 잘못되지 않을 거라는 거예요. 사실상
고전적 계산은 기본적으로 완벽하니까요. 예를 들어, 표면 코드 오류에 대한 수정을
계산하기 위해 고전적인 매칭 알고리즘을 실행하면, 이 고전적 계산이 잘못될 거라고 걱정할 필요는 없어요. 하지만 양자 정보를 직접
다루는 건 달라요. 물론, 다양한 오류 발생 확률을 연결할 수 있는 정확한 모델이 필요해요.
원한다면 현실을 최대한 반영하는 복잡한 모델을 만들 수도 있어요.
하지만 모델이 너무 복잡하면 다루기 어렵거나 불가능해지고, 흥미로운 결론을 이끌어내기 어려울 수 있어요.
사람들이 자주 고려하는 아주 단순한 노이즈 모델 중 하나는
독립적인 확률적 노이즈 모델인데요, 서로 다른 구성 요소에 영향을 미치는 오류나 결함이
다른 순간에, 즉 circuit의 다른 위치에서 독립적으로 발생한다는 모델이에요.
예를 들어, 모든 gate는 일정한 확률로 실패하고, 저장된 qubit에서는 단위 시간당 다른 확률로 비트 플립과 위상 플립이 발생한다고 볼 수 있어요.
하지만 가정은 서로 다른 오류 사이에 상관관계가 없다는 거예요.
이 모델에 반론을 제기할 수도 있어요. 오류 사이에 어느 정도 상관관계가 있을 가능성이 높으니까요.
예를 들어, 모든 qubit을 한 번에 날려버리는 치명적인 오류가 발생할 확률이 낮지만 있을 수도 있어요.
혹은 더 가능성 높은 경우로, 여러 구성 요소에 영향을 미치지만 특정 위치에 집중된 오류가 있을 수도 있어요.
이를 부정하는 사람은 없어요. 하지만 이 모델은 자연은 예측 불가능하지만 악의적이지는 않고
양자 계산을 의도적으로 망치려 하지 않는다는 아이디어를 나타내는 간단한 기준선이 돼요.
더 현실적이라고 볼 수 있는 다른 노이즈 모델들도 많이 고려돼요. 어떤 모델을 선택하든,
모델이 잘못된 방향으로 이끌고 작업 중인 시스템의 오류에 대해 새로운 것을 알게 되면,
자연스럽게 다른 오류 모델을 만들고 고려할 수 있어요. 다음으로,
양자 circuit을 내결함성 방식으로 구현하는 기본 전략을 살펴볼게요. 주어진
논리적 양자 circuit, 즉 실행하고 싶은 이상적인 양자 circuit을 생각해 봐요. 예를 들어, 앞서 본 것과 같은 circuit을 고려할 수 있는데,
내결함성 구현을 위한 공간이 좀 더 필요해서 조금 늘어난 버전이에요.
먼저, 상태 준비, 유니터리 gate, 측정은 단일 gate나 단일 qubit 측정 또는 상태 준비로 직접 수행되는 게 아니라,
소위 가젯(gadget)으로 수행돼요. 이 가젯은 각각 여러 qubit과 여러 연산을 포함할 수 있어요.
이 다이어그램에서는 이걸 보라색 박스로 표시했어요.
이 보라색 박스들은 우리가 구현하려는 상태 준비나 gate로 레이블이 붙은 작은 circuit이나 연산이라고 생각하면 돼요.
두 번째로, 오류 정정 코드를 사용해서 qubit을 보호해야 해요. 따라서 이 다른 가젯들을 연결하는 건 논리적 qubit 자체가 아니라, 가젯이
이 논리적 qubit을 인코딩하는 물리적 qubit에 작용해요. 여기서 중요한 점은 우리가 관심 있는 논리적 qubit은
절대 노출되지 않는다는 거예요. 즉, 이 논리적 qubit들은 우리가 사용하는 양자 오류 정정 코드의 보호 아래
평생을 보내게 돼요. 마지막으로, 계산 전반에 걸쳐 기회가 생길 때마다
인코딩된 qubit에 반복적으로 오류 정정을 수행해요. 이게 정말 중요해요.
직관적으로, 오류가 발생하면 qubit 상태에 무작위성이나 불확실성이 쌓이기 시작하고,
우리는 이 무작위성이나 엔트로피를 지속적으로 제거해야 해요. 그게 바로 오류 정정을 통해 이루어져요.
이 오류 정정 단계들을 논리적 냉장고나 열 펌프처럼 생각할 수 있어요.
논리적 qubit이 차갑게 유지되어 계산이 올바르게 작동할 수 있도록 해주는 거예요.
모든 선택이 이루어지면, 즉 모든 가젯과 코드의 선택, 그리고 특정 노이즈 모델을 가정하면,
우리가 스스로에게 물어볼 수 있는 근본적인 질문이 있어요. 과연 이게 실제로 도움이 되고 있냐는 거예요.
상황을 더 좋게 만들고 있는 건지, 아니면 더 나쁘게 만들고 있는 건지요? 노이즈가 너무 많으면
오히려 상황을 악화시킬 수 있어요. 오류 확률이 너무 높으면 9큐비트 Shor 코드가 상황을 악화시키는 것처럼요.
하지만 노이즈가 특정 임계값 아래라면, 이 모든 추가 작업이 효과를 낼 거예요. 강의 말미에 다룰 것처럼,
오류를 더 줄이는 길이 열려요. 이 부분에서는 방금 설명한 기본 구조를 가진 내결함성 양자
circuit에서의 오류 전파에 대해 다룰 거예요. 이건 매우 중요한 문제인데,
오류 전파를 제어하지 못하면 오류가 우리의 오류
정정 노력을 금방 압도해버려요. 하지만 오류 전파를 제어할 수 있다면, 코드가 오류를 충분히 높은 속도로 정정하여
계산이 작동할 수 있도록 훨씬 좋은 기회를 가질 수 있어요.
이 논의의 출발점은 2-qubit gate, 혹은 더 일반적으로 다중 qubit gate가
올바르게 작동하더라도 오류를 전파시킬 수 있다는 인식이에요.
예를 들어, CNOT gate를 생각해 봐요. CNOT gate가 수행되기 전에 제어 qubit에 X 오류가 발생한다고 가정해요.
X 오류는 X gate처럼 작동해요. 그래서
왼쪽의 circuit은 CNOT 이후 두 qubit 모두에 X 오류가 발생하는 오른쪽 circuit과 동일해요.
이게 오류 전파예요. 왼쪽에서 X 오류의 불운한 위치가 사실상 오른쪽에서 두 개의 X 오류로 바뀌는 거예요.
이걸 피할 방법은 없어요. CNOT gate를 사용하는 한, 항상 그 직전에 제어 qubit에 X 오류가 발생할 가능성이 있고,
그러면 이후에 두 개의 X 오류로 전파돼요. 하지만 볼 수 있듯이, 이로 인한 피해를 제한하는 조치를 취하면 괜찮아요.
그런데, CNOT 직전에 타겟 qubit에 Z 오류가 발생하는 경우도 같은 현상이 일어나요.
이건 앞서 다뤘고, 이 등식들은 곱셈을 직접 수행하거나 Qiskit을 사용해서 확인할 수 있어요.
결론은 두 경우 모두 여러 qubit에 걸쳐 상관된 오류가 발생한다는 거예요. 물론
CNOT gate 자체도 결함이 있을 수 있고, 이 역시 상관된
오류를 유발할 수 있어요. 게다가 이후의 2-qubit gate들이 이 오류를 더 전파시킬 수 있어요.
예를 들어, X 안정자 생성원을 측정할 때처럼 이런 식으로 CNOT gate가 세 개 있다면, 단일 오류가
금방 여러 qubit으로 전파될 수 있어요. 이게 하나의 코드 블록 내에서 발생한다면, 즉 함께 논리적 qubit을 인코딩하는
qubit 묶음에서 발생한다면, 우리가 선택한 오류 정정 코드는 아무 소용이 없어요.
코드는 저가중 오류를 정정하도록 설계되어 있지, 이런 고가중 오류를 정정하도록 설계된 게 아니니까요.
따라서 내결함성 양자 circuit에서 가젯과 오류 정정 단계를 생각할 때
이 점을 항상 염두에 두어야 해요. 내결함성 양자
circuit에서 오류 전파를 완화하는 가장 단순하게 알려진 방법은 gate를 횡단적으로 구현하는 거예요.
무슨 뜻인지 곧 설명할게요. 내결함성 circuit 구현 그림을 시각적 도구로 화면에 띄워둘게요.
여기서의 아이디어는 일부 양자 오류 정정 코드의 경우 특정 gate를 횡단적으로 구현할 수 있다는 거예요.
이건 각 연산이 각 코드 블록 내의 단일 qubit 위치에만 작용하는 연산들의 텐서 곱인 가젯을 사용해서 구현한다는 의미예요.
예시를 통해 설명하는 게 가장 쉬워요.
첫 번째이자 가장 단순한 예시는 Pauli gate의 횡단적 구현이에요.
아이디어는 circuit의 각 gate에 대한 가젯을 만드는 거예요. 모든 경우에서 이 가젯들은 텔레포테이션 circuit의 마지막에 있는 X와 Z gate에서처럼 코드 블록에 작용해요.
물론, 디코딩 후 Pauli gate를 적용하고 다시 인코딩하는 방식은 쓸 수 없어요.
그러면 논리적 qubit이 보호받지 못하는 상태가 되고, 재인코딩 결과로 코드 블록 내에서 오류가 전파될 수 있거든요.
다행히, 안정자 코드를 사용하는 한 그럴 필요가 없어요. 모든 안정자 코드는 Pauli
연산을 논리적 qubit에 직접 적용할 수 있거든요. 실제로 인코딩에 사용된 물리적 qubit에 Pauli gate의 텐서 곱으로
그렇게 할 수 있어요.
예를 들어, 이전 강의 말미에 나온 3x3 surface code를 생각해보면, 이 코드로 인코딩된 논리적 qubit에 X와 Z gate를 구현할 수 있어요.
여기 제시된 패턴대로 X와 Z gate를 항등 gate와 함께 텐서 결합하는 방식으로요.
이건 이 gate들의 횡단적 구현이에요.
예를 들어, 이전 강의 말미에 나온 3x3 surface code를 생각해보면, 이 코드로 인코딩된 논리적 qubit에 X와 Z gate를 구현할 수 있어요.
여기 제시된 패턴대로 X와 Z gate를 항등 gate와 함께 텐서 결합하면 되는데, 이 패턴들은
여기서 제시돼요. 이건 이 gate들의 횡단적 구현인데, 각각의 개별 gate 연산이
각 코드 블록 내의 단일 qubit 위치에만 작용하기 때문이에요.
여기서는 단일 qubit gate만 사용하니까 어떤 면에서는 사소한 내용이지만, 어쨌든 이런 가젯은 오류를
전파시키지 않아요. 물론 이런 가젯에서 개별 gate 중 어느 하나가 실패할 수 있고, 그러면 오류가 생기지만,
모든 가젯 직후에 항상 오류 정정을 수행해요. 오류율이 충분히
낮다면, 오류 정정 코드가 그 오류들을 정정할 거예요.
앞서 말한 대로, 이건 모든 안정자 코드에서 Pauli gate에 대해 항상 가능해요.
다만, 구현하려는 논리적 Pauli 연산에 맞게 가젯에서 올바른 Pauli gate 패턴을 찾아야 해요.
2-qubit gate를 포함하는 또 다른 예시를 볼게요. 이번엔 CNOT gate의 횡단적 구현을
살펴볼 거예요. 특히, 모든 CSS 코드에서 CNOT gate를
두 논리적 qubit 사이에 구현하려면 단순히 대응하는 물리적 qubit 쌍에
CNOT gate를 수행하면 돼요. 이건 횡단적 조건을 만족하는데, 각각의 개별 CNOT gate가
각 코드 블록 내의 단일 qubit 위치에만 작용하기 때문이에요. 예를 들어, 첫 번째 CNOT gate는 각 코드 블록에서 맨 위 qubit에만 작용하고,
두 번째 CNOT gate는 위에서 두 번째 qubit에만 작용하는 식이에요.
이 경우에는 오류 전파가 발생할 수 있어요. CNOT gate는 오류를 전파하고 그걸
막을 방법이 없거든요. 하지만 핵심은 오류 전파가 절대 하나의 코드 블록 내에서 일어나지 않는다는 거예요.
예를 들어, 가젯이 수행되기 직전에 위쪽 코드 블록의 맨 위 qubit에 X 오류가 발생하면, 가젯 안의 첫 번째 CNOT이
그 오류를 아래쪽 블록의 맨 위 qubit으로 전파해요. 하지만 결과로 생긴 두 오류는
이제 서로 다른 코드 블록에 있어요. 따라서 가젯 이후에 수행되는 오류 정정 단계가 그 오류들을 개별적으로 정정할 수 있어요.
각 코드 블록 내에서 단일 qubit에만 영향을 미치는 오류니까요.
반면, 오류 전파가 같은 코드 블록 내에서 일어난다면 문제가 될 수 있어요.
오류 전파가 저가중 오류를 코드가 처리하지 못할 수 있는 고가중 오류로 바꾸기 때문이에요.
이 구현 방식은 비CSS 코드에는 통하지 않지만, CSS 코드를 사용하는 한 항상 이런 방식으로 CNOT
gate를 횡단적으로 구현할 수 있어요. 한 가지 더, 모든
Clifford gate는 steane 코드에 대해 횡단적으로 구현할 수 있어요. 사실 어떤 색깔 코드에 대해서도 가능해요. 색깔 코드의 정말 좋은 점 중 하나인데, Hadamard gate는 논리적 qubit에
각 물리적 qubit에 Hadamard gate를 개별적으로 수행하는 방식으로 구현할 수 있고, 논리적 S gate는 각 qubit에 S gate가 아니라
각 물리적 qubit에 S dagger gate로 구현할 수 있어요. 결론적으로, 횡단적 gate 구현은 본질적으로
내결함성이에요. 하나의 코드 블록 내에서 오류를 절대 전파하지 않기 때문에, 오류 정정 단계가 이 가젯에 사용된 gate들로 인해 발생하거나 전파된
오류들을 정정할 기회를 가질 수 있거든요. 정말 좋은 방식이고,
내결함성 가젯을 구축하는 아주 단순한 방법이에요. 또한 T gate 같은 다른 gate의 횡단적 구현을 허용하는
다양한 코드들이 있어요. 하지만 안타깝게도, 비자명 코드로는
범용 gate 집합을 횡단적으로 구현하는 게 불가능해요. 이건 Eastin-Knill 정리로 알려진 사실이에요.
더 기술적으로 말하면, 코드의 거리가 적어도 2 이상인 한 횡단적으로 구현할 수 있는 gate들의 집합은
전역 위상을 제외하면 반드시 이산적인 연산들의 집합을 생성해요. 따라서 이 집합은 범용이 아니에요.
범용 gate 집합은 반드시 무한히 많은 연산을 생성하거든요. 이 정리의 증명은 설명하지 않을게요.
이 증명은 이 시리즈의 전제 조건이 아닌 리 군과 리 대수에 관한 기본 사실들을 사용하거든요. 하지만 기본 아이디어는
횡단적 연산의 무한한 族이 코드 공간 내에 머물 수 없다는 거예요.
횡단적 연산의 미세한 차이는 코드가 오류로 감지하는 저가중 Pauli 연산으로 잘 근사되기 때문이에요.
따라서 gate를 횡단적으로 구현할 수 있을 때는 정말 좋아요. 하지만 어떤 코드를 선택하든,
이 방식으로 구현할 수 없는 gate가 항상 있다는 걸 알 수 있어요. 그래서 대안적인 가젯을 찾아야 해요.
Eastin-Knill 정리에 따르면, 거리 2짜리 양자 오류 정정 코드에 대해서조차 횡단적으로 범용 양자 gate 집합을 구현하는 건 불가능해요.
따라서 적어도 일부 gate에 대해서는 내결함성 방식으로 구현하는 다른 방법을 찾아야 해요.
잘 알려진 방법 중 하나는 소위 magic state를 이용하는 거예요.
이 논의를 위해, 화면에 나와 있는 대로 정의된 S gate와 T gate를
떠올려 봐요. 두 가지를 확인해 볼게요. 먼저 S gate는 Clifford 연산이에요.
Clifford 연산의 정의에서 따라오는 건데, Pauli 행렬을 S로 켤레 변환하면 항상 플러스 또는 마이너스 다른 Pauli
행렬이 나온다는 걸 확인할 수 있어요. 그리고 두 번째로, T gate는 Clifford 연산이 아니에요. 실제로 T를 Hadamard와 CNOT과 결합하면,
둘 다 Clifford 연산인데, 범용 양자 gate 집합이 돼요. 따라서 T gate를
Clifford 연산과 표준 기저 측정만으로는 구현할 수 없어요. 하지만 실제로 T gate를
Clifford 연산과 표준 기저 측정으로 구현할 수 있어요. 화면에 나와 있는 상태의 복사본이 하나 더 있다면요.
그 상태는 플러스 상태에 T gate를 적용한 거예요.
화면에 나와 있는 그 상태, 즉 플러스 상태에 T gate를 적용한 거예요.
이 상태를 magic state라고 해요. 이게 유일한 건 아니지만요.
magic state라는 용어는 이 변형 방식 전체에서 비슷한 역할을 하는 다른 상태들을 가리키는 데도 써요.
예를 들어, 여기 보이는 circuit이 그 역할을 해요. 확인하는 게 그렇게 어렵진 않아요.
윗 시스템을 오른쪽에 두고 초기 상태가 있어요. CNOT gate를 적용하고 정리하면,
여기 나와 있는 상태가 돼요.
아래 qubit을 측정해서 0을 얻으면, 이건 확률 1/2로 일어나는데, S gate를 적용하지 않고
출력은 s에 T를 적용한 결과예요.
1을 측정하면, 이것도 물론 확률 1/2로 일어나는데, S gate를 적용하고, 결과는
출력이 또다시 s에 T를 적용한 거예요. 그런데 이게 유일한 방법은 아니에요. 비슷하게 생긴
circuit들도 같은 작업을 수행하지만, 이건 한 가지 방법이에요.
이건 4강에서 언급했던 양자 gate 텔레포테이션이라고 알려진 것의 다소 단순화된 예시예요. 텔레포테이션을 이용해서
qubit을 보내는 게 아니라 gate를 적용하는 데 사용돼요. 텔레포테이션과의 연결이 여기서 완전히 명확하지 않을 수도 있어요. 제가
말했듯이, 이건 T가 대각 행렬이기 때문에 가능한 단순화된 버전이에요. 더 알고 싶다면
키워드는 '양자 gate 텔레포테이션'이에요.
그리고 비슷하게 S gate를 구현할 수도 있어요. 이번엔 CNOT gate와 Z gate, 그리고 측정만 필요해요.
횡단적 S gate 구현이 없을 때 유용해요. 흥미롭긴 하지만
이게 실제로 도움이 되는지 완전히 명확하지는 않아요. T gate 구현의 경우, 우리는
입력 상태에 T gate를 적용하고 있어요. 하지만 그러려면 플러스 상태에 T gate를 적용해서
magic state를 만드는 것처럼 보여요. S gate 구현도 비슷해요. 여기서 핵심은
magic state를 얻기 위해 꼭 먼저 플러스 상태를 만들고 T gate를 적용할 필요는 없다는 거예요. 이 상태를 얻는 다른 방법들이 있어요.
특히, magic state 생성이 별도로 이루어지기 때문에 실제로 수행 중인 계산에서 오류가 전파될 걱정 없이 이걸 할 수 있어요.
이를 통해 T gate의 내결함성 구현이 가능해요. 지금 간략하게 설명할게요.
먼저, 여기 보이는 단순한 2-qubit circuit을 실제로 실행하는 게 아니라, 내결함성 구현에 사용 중인 오류 정정 코드로
인코딩된 qubit을 사용해서 이 circuit을 실행할 거예요. 즉,
유니터리 gate와 측정은 내결함성 가젯으로 수행돼요. 그래서 우리의
magic state도 인코딩되어야 해요. 그러면 인코딩된 magic state만 손에 넣을 수 있다면 모든 게 내결함성으로 작동해요.
그런데 여기서 S gate에 대한 내결함성 가젯이 이미 있다고 가정하고 있어요.
예를 들어 steane 코드를 사용한다면 S gate를 횡단적으로 구현하면 돼요. 그게 안 되는 코드의 경우, 한 가지 옵션은
이 전체 방식을 먼저 사용해서 S gate를 내결함성으로 구현한 다음 여기서 그 구현을 사용하는 거예요.
그게 유일한 옵션은 아니지만요. 어쨌든, 구현으로 돌아와서, 남은 중요한 질문은 어떻게
인코딩된 magic state를 손에 넣느냐예요. 그걸 위한 내결함성 T gate 구현이 아직 없으니 단순하게 할 수가 없잖아요.
핵심 아이디어는 확률적 프로세스를 이용해서 인코딩된 magic state를 만들 수 있다는 거예요. 잘 안 되면
괜찮아요. 실패한 시도는 버리고 다시 시도하면 되니까요.
그게 실제로 수행 중인 계산을 방해하지 않아요. magic state 생성은
별도로 이루어지니까요. 이게 이루어지는 전형적인 방법은 magic state 증류라고 알려진 프로세스예요.
작동 방식은 이래요. 증류기라는 특정 circuit이 있어요. 여기에 잡음이 있는 magic
state 모음을 입력한 다음, 출력 중 하나를 제외한 나머지를 모두 측정해요. 측정 결과가 모두 0이 되면,
나오는 건 잡음이 더 적은 magic state예요. 그게 다음 증류기 입력 qubit 중 하나가 될 수 있어요.
그리고 이 프로세스는 측정 결과 중 하나가 0이 아니어서 실패하고 다시 시도하거나, 우리가 관심 있는 계산에서 T gate를 구현하는 데 안전하게 사용할 수 있을 만큼 품질이 충분히 높은 magic
state가 생길 때까지 계속돼요.
이런 증류기를 만드는 다양한 방법이 알려져 있지만, 모두 기본적으로 같은 방식으로 작동해요. 안정자 코드의 디코더예요.
즉, 인코딩 circuit의 역(逆)이에요. 이건 증류기가 Clifford
연산이 될 수 있다는 걸 의미하기 때문에 좋아요. 그리고 이 증류 프로세스는 실제로 논리적 qubit 수준에서 이루어져요. 그래서 실제로는
모두 증류기와 측정을 위한 가젯을 사용해서 수행돼요. 이 프로세스는
어디선가 시작해야 해요. 하지만 노이즈 수준이 너무 높지 않은 한, 잡음이 있지만 충분히 좋은
magic state를 만들어서 시작할 수 있어요. 예를 들어, 플러스 상태의 qubit에 실제 잡음이 있는 T gate를 적용한 다음
그 qubit을 인코딩하는 방식으로요. 아주 높은 수준의 설명이었지만, 이게 어떻게 작동하는지 대략적인 아이디어는 드렸을 거예요.
gate를 횡단적으로 구현하는 것보다 훨씬 복잡하지만, 어쨌든 범용 양자 gate 집합을
내결함성 방식으로 구현하는 방법을 제공해요. 횡단적 gate 구현만으로는 그게 안 되죠. 때때로 이런 방식으로
magic state를 이용해서 gate를 내결함성으로 구현하는 오버헤드가 매우 높을 거라고 주장되는데,
작업의 대부분이 magic state를 증류하는 데 들어가고 실제 계산 실행은 부차적인 것이 된다는 거예요.
하지만 그게 꼭 그렇지는 않아요. 이 방법이
실제로 실용적일 수 있다고 밝혀준 상세한 분석도 있어요. 내결함성 gate 구현을 위한 다른 알려진 방식들도 여러 가지 있어요. 코드 변형과 코드 전환은
이런 방식들과 관련된 이름들이고, 새로운 방법들이 계속 개발되고 개선되고 있지만, 이 강의에서 그 방법들은 설명하지 않을 거예요.
내결함성 양자 circuit 구현과 관련된 또 다른 중요한 문제가 있는데,
바로 오류 정정 단계 자체예요. 이건 gate 구현에 관한 게 아니에요.
실제 오류 정정에 관한 거예요. 문제는 14강에서 처음 봤던 간단한 circuit들을 생각해보면,
위상 추정에 기반한 안정자 생성원 측정을 위한 circuit들이 있는데, 그 circuit들이
그 자체로 내결함성이 아니에요. 단일 코드 블록 내에서 오류가 전파될 수 있기 때문이에요.
이건 양자 정보를 포함하는 모든 것이 오류에 취약하다는 아이디어로 돌아가요. 오류를 정정하기 위한 circuit 자체도 마찬가지예요.
꽤 문제스럽게 보이지만, 실제로 이 문제에 대한 알려진 해결책이 여러 가지 있어요. 몇 가지만
언급할게요. 자세히 설명하진 않겠지만요. 그런데 내결함성 양자 컴퓨팅이
복잡하고 걱정해야 할 세부 사항이 많다는 느낌이 든다면, 그건 이해할 수 있어요. 실제로 그러니까요. 움직이는 부분이 많고,
이 강의에서 제 목적은 모든 세부 사항을 설명하는 게 아니라 이 모든 게 어떻게 작동하는지에 대한 기본적인 소개를 드리는 거예요.
내결함성 양자 오류 정정의 한 방법은 Peter
Shor가 처음 제안한 방법을 따서 Shor 오류 정정이라고 해요. 아이디어는 소위 cat state를 이용해서 각 신드롬 측정을 수행하는 거예요.
3 qubit일 때 GHZ 상태와 동일한데, 측정하려는 안정자 생성원의 가중치와 일치하는 임의의 qubit 수로 일반화할 수 있어요.
특히, 여기 나와 있는 circuit이 안정자 생성원 측정에 작동해요.
이 방법이 코드 블록 내에서 오류를 전파시키지 않는다는 게 증명될 수 있어요.
cat state 자체를 만들 필요가 있어요. 오류와 잠재적으로 결함이 있는 gate가 있는 상황에서 안정적으로 작동하려면, 이 방법은 실제로
이런 circuit을 반복적으로 실행하고 프로세스 도중 다양한 오류가 어디서 발생했는지 추론해야 해요.
또 다른 방법은 Andrew Steane이 처음 제안한 Steane 오류 정정이에요.
이 방법은 다르게 작동하고 CSS 코드에서만 작동해요. 이 방법에서는 실행 중인 circuit의 인코딩된 양자 상태에 신드롬 측정을 직접 수행하는 게 아니라, 의도적으로 작업 공간 시스템으로 오류를 전파시켜
그 시스템을 측정하고 고전적으로 오류를 감지해요. 여기 나와 있는 그림은 X 오류에 대해 이걸 어떻게 하는지 보여주는데, 이 경우 작업 공간
qubit들은 처음에 플러스 상태의 인코딩으로 설정돼요. 기본적으로
CNOT gate의 횡단적 구현인데, 타겟이 플러스 상태에 있기 때문에 아무것도 안 해야 해요. 하지만
위쪽 qubit들에 X 오류가 있었다면 아래 시스템으로 전파되어 감지될 거예요. Z 오류를 감지하는 비슷한 방법도 있는데
여기서는 나와 있지 않아요. Manny Knill이 처음 제안한 Knill 오류 정정이라고 알려진 관련 방법도 있는데,
횡단적 CNOT 대신 텔레포테이션을 기반으로 해서 임의의 안정자
코드에 사용할 수 있어요.
CSS 코드만이 아니라요.
이 강의에서 마지막으로 다룰 것은 임계값 정리라고 알려진 아주 중요한 정리예요. 정리의 다소 비공식적인
진술을 살펴볼게요. n이 얼마나 크든 간에 n개의 gate를 가진 양자 circuit이 있다면,
노이즈 수준이 n에 무관한 특정 임계값 아래인 노이즈 양자 circuit을 사용해서 높은 정확도로 그 circuit을 구현하는 게 가능하다는 거예요.
그리고 이 임계값은 n에 독립적이에요. 게다가, 이걸 하는 데 너무 비싸지 않아요.
필요한 노이즈 circuit의 크기가 n에 n의 로그의 어떤 상수 제곱을 곱한 정도이기 때문이에요.
정리를 더 공식적으로 서술하려면 노이즈 모델에 대해 구체적으로 이야기해야 하는데, 이 강의에서는 그렇게 하지 않을 거예요.
예를 들어, 앞서 언급한 독립적인 확률적 노이즈 모델에 대해 증명할 수 있어요. 이 모델에서는 오류가
이 임계값보다 엄격하게 작은 확률로 circuit의 각 가능한 위치에서 독립적으로 발생해요. 하지만
오류 사이에 상관관계가 있을 수 있는 더 일반적인 노이즈 모델에 대해서도 증명할 수 있어요. 이건 이론적인
결과이고, 일반적으로 증명하는 방식이 실제로 우리가 할 일을 꼭 반영하지는 않지만, 그럼에도 불구하고 실용적 측면에서 매우
중요한 정리예요. 그 이유는 노이즈가 있는 구성 요소를 사용해서
양자 계산을 수행하는 데 근본적인 장벽이 없다고 기본적으로 말해주기 때문이에요.
이 구성 요소들의 오류율이 임계값 아래인 한, 임의의 크기의 신뢰할 수 있는 양자 circuit을
구축하는 데 사용할 수 있어요. 다르게 말하면, 이 정리가 사실이 아니었다면 대규모 양자 컴퓨팅이
현실이 되는 걸 상상하기 어렵겠죠. 이 정리의 공식적인 증명에는 많은 기술적 세부 사항이 있는데,
전달하려고 시도하지는 않을 거예요. 하지만 높은 수준에서 기본 아이디어를 설명하고, 또한
기본 아이디어를 실제로 일어날 수 있는 것과 느슨하게 연결해 볼게요. 이게 우리의 circuit이에요. 강의 전체에서 이야기해온 circuit이에요.
하지만 circuit이 이것보다 훨씬 크고 복잡할 수 있다고 상상할 수 있어요. 이 circuit을
구현하고 싶지만 모든 구성 요소에 노이즈가 있어요. 독립적인 확률적 노이즈
모델을 단순성을 위해 사용한다고 가정하면, 각 가능한 위치에서 독립적으로 오류가 발생하는 확률 P가 있어요.
circuit이 이 확률 P의 역수보다 훨씬 크다면, 직접
구현이 올바르게 작동하지 않을 거라고 꽤 확신할 수 있어요. 그래서 지금까지 강의에서 이야기한 대로
circuit을 내결함성으로 구현하는 모든 과정을 거치고, 앞서 제기한 질문, 즉 상황을 더 좋게 만들고 있는지
아니면 더 나쁘게 만들고 있는지 스스로에게 물어봐요. 각 구성 요소의 오류 확률을 나타내는 확률 P가 너무 크다면
도움이 안 돼요. 오류 확률이 3/4% 이상이면 9-qubit Shor 코드가 도움이 안 되는 것처럼요.
특히, 이제 circuit이 더 커졌어요. 오류가 발생할 수 있는 위치가 훨씬 많아진 거예요.
하지만 P가 충분히 작다면 도움이 돼요. 실질적으로 우리가 수행하는 논리적 계산의 오류
확률을 줄이는 거예요. 좀 더 자세히 생각해 봐요.
가능한 한 단순한 설정에서 주요 아이디어를 보기 위해, 오류 정정에 7-qubit steane 코드를 사용한다고 가정해요.
이 코드는 코드 블록당 최대 하나의 오류를 정정할 수 있어요. 따라서 원래 circuit에서 논리적 오류가
발생하려면 내결함성 구현에서 같은 코드 블록에 최소 두 개의 오류가
있어야 해요.
같은 코드 블록에 두 개 이상의 오류가 발생하는 다양한 방법이 있다는 걸 염두에 두면, 원래 circuit의 각 위치에서 논리적 오류가 발생할 확률은
최대 C * P^2임을 주장할 수 있어요. C는 코드와 우리가 사용하는
가젯에 따라 달라지는 숫자예요. 하지만 결정적으로 원래 circuit의 크기에는 의존하지 않아요.
따라서 P가 C의 역수보다 작으면, 이게 임계값으로 취할 수 있는 숫자인데, 이것은
오류 감소로 이어져요. 따라서 circuit을 내결함성으로 구현하는 수고가 효과를 내는 거예요.
하지만 이 새로운 오류율이 전체 circuit이 올바르게 작동하기엔 여전히 너무 높을 수 있어요. 더 해야 해요.
실제로는 이 시점에서 자연스럽게 더 좋은 코드와 더 좋은 가젯을 선택해서 오류율을
구현이 작동할 가능성이 있는 수준까지 낮추는 거예요.
이론적으로, 이게 가능하다고 주장하는 간단한 방법은 연결(concatenate)이에요. 즉,
원래 circuit의 내결함성 구현을 새로운 논리적 circuit으로 생각하는 거예요. 그런 다음 내결함성으로
구현해요. 그리고 필요한 만큼 몇 번이고 반복해요. 이게 오류를
아주 빠르게 줄여요. 이게 바로 임계값 정리가 종이 위에서 일반적으로 증명되는 방식이에요.
공식적으로 증명하는 데 필요한 많은 기술적 세부 사항을 생략하고 오류율이 어떻게 감소하는지 아주 대략적인 아이디어만 알려드릴게요.
원래 구성 요소의 오류 확률 P로 시작해요. circuit을 내결함성으로
구현하면 오류는 C * P 인수만큼 감소해요. 그런 다음 내결함성
구현을 논리적 circuit으로 취급하고 내결함성으로 구현하면 오류율이 비슷하게 감소해요. 하지만
원래 circuit의 유효 오류율을 생각해보면, 훨씬 더 많이 감소한다는 걸 알 수 있어요. 이제
오류율 P를 C * P^2로 대체하고 있거든요. 첫 번째 수준 내결함성 구현 이후의 유효 오류율이 그거니까요.
구체적으로, 약간의 대수 계산 후에 오류는 CP^3 * P로
감소해요. 한 번 더 하면 오류율은 CP^7 * P가 돼요.
총 K 수준으로 계속하면, 오류는 K에 대해 이중 지수적으로 줄어들어요. 오류율을 아주 작게 만들기 위해
이걸 아주 많이 반복할 필요는 없어요.
한편, circuit의 크기는 커지지만 크기는 K에 대해 단일 지수적으로만 증가해요. 각
내결함성 수준마다 circuit의 크기가 가젯의 최대 크기에 의해 결정되는 인수만큼만 증가하기 때문이에요.
이 모든 것을 합치고 연결 수준의 수에 대해 적절한 선택을 하면,
임계값 정리를 얻어요. 하지만 이미 제안했듯이, 이걸 공식화하려면 많은 세부 사항이 필요해요.
그럼 현실에서 이 임계값은 어떤 값일까요? 코드와 가젯에 따라 달라요.
magic state 증류와 함께 steane 코드를 사용하는 경우, 아주 작고 실제로 달성하기 어려울 것 같아요.
하지만 surface code와 최첨단 가젯을 사용하면 약 1%로 추정돼요.
나쁘지 않아요. 새로운 코드와 방법이 발견됨에 따라 임계값이 증가할 것이라고 합리적으로 기대할 수 있고, 동시에
우리가 구축하는 구성 요소의 노이즈 수준도 감소할 거예요. 대규모 양자 계산을 내결함성으로 구현할 수 있는 지점에 도달하는 건
쉽지 않을 거고 하룻밤 사이에 일어나지도 않을 거예요.
하지만 이 정리와 지금까지 목격한 양자 코드 및 양자 하드웨어의 발전이
대규모 내결함성 양자 컴퓨터를 구축하는 이 궁극적인 목표를 향해 계속 나아갈 수 있는 낙관론을 제공해요.
그게 강의의 끝이자 시리즈의 끝이에요.
이 시리즈가 도움이 됐으면 정말 좋겠어요. 그렇다면 동료나 친구에게 추천해 주세요.
또한, 추가 강좌와 튜토리얼을 위해 IBM Quantum Learning을 꼭 확인해 보시고, Qiskit
YouTube 채널을 아직 구독하지 않으셨다면 구독해서 미래 콘텐츠 공개에 최신 상태를 유지하세요.
시청해 주셔서 감사해요.